[Applause]
we officially have an nba finals
that's right two teams have made it
through the bubble the lakers and the
heat
and um as jimmy butler said so
eloquently
the road to an nba championship is
through a lebron
james lead team and that is happening
this year
lakers versus heat i want to have a
quick conversation about jimmy butler
yeah for those of you guys who don't
follow basketball very much
jimmy butler is a player that is an
enigma he's someone who is always like
he's really fascinating man like yeah i
think the closest thing that we have
in the past to jimmy butler is charles
barkley
like a guy who really just kind of what
is it a move to the beat of his own drum
i was gonna say if you remember ricky
williams in football
ricky williams i think that's
disrespecting jimmy a little bit i think
jimmy's
stronger mentally than ricky like didn't
ricky like have like an emotional
breakdown ricky was a little emotional
but
just in the sense that just kind of like
just his own guy you can't figure this
guy out yeah ricky williams also had a
couple of great seasons and they abused
this guy like random way too much and
yeah probably in his career early but
just in that sense of like
i don't exactly understand what i'm
looking at but i'm going to do what i
want to do but he does what he wants to
do and i appreciate that
i [ __ ] with you on that for sure and
jimmy definitely has that jimmy will do
whatever he wants to go fishing he'll go
fishing that's just what he's gonna do
um he is a unique individual he's fine
being himself
he's fine giving it up for his teammates
you know i mean like this is a
nba veteran making tons of money where's
his rookie teammates jersey
after one of the games like who tyler
harrow had a great game but still like
it is humbling to do that as a vote you
know like i don't know if lebron is
walking around with some rookie
that had a good game i don't know if
he's walking around caruso's jersey if
he has a good game it's humbling to do
that to yourself you know
and but he also will [ __ ] on his
teammates
he broke andrew wiggins yeah i mean not
that wiggins was really flying before
but like
he mentally he couldn't handle it
emotionally and what was really
interesting about jimmy is that he
always had this ability
amazing ability but some people looked
at him like a head case yeah and then he
would get
under his teammate's skin and what's
really interesting what's happened with
the heat is he
found an environment that was conducive
to
his attitude about com uh competition
yeah
right pat riley is an old school
[ __ ] with the here
he is okay with that trash talk he's
okay with alpha players
being alphas he's okay with a culture
that allows that to live and breathe and
jimmy who went to
he was at chicago then he went to
minnesota yeah right then he went to the
76ers
then he lands in miami it has this
amazing
bubble experience in miami
it seems like he finally found the team
that has a culture where he can thrive
and i'm watching jimmy and what he's
been doing and how successful he's been
leading his team
right and i'm starting to think
is everything that we've liked about
russell westbrook
what we should have been liking about
jimmy butler
i think so is jimmy that's a great way
to put it
is jimmy butler the real russell
westbrook
that's like [ __ ] don't get me wrong
like russell westbrook is is an athletic
marvel and he's such a great competitor
but like
his way of playing the game usually
doesn't help his team win no and in
times it actually hurts it
yeah jimmy is a dog he's out there doing
whatever it takes if it's d enough the
toughest guy on the other team
if it's scoring if it's bigging up his
teammate if he's screaming everybody
he's a motivator
but he's a [ __ ] winner especially
what he's done this time during the
bubble
and i'm wondering if everything that
we've loved about westbrook we really
actually love about jimmy he just wasn't
in the environment
where he could do it and to be honest i
owe him an apology because
i loved jimmy but then after he left
philly i was like maybe at some point
the problem is you
yeah yeah you left chicago it seems like
bad terms you left minnesota on horrible
terms
you don't seem to leave philly on good
terms maybe it's you yeah then it turns
out i think he just needed the right
culture
he doesn't i don't think he understands
this new star
i think lebron understands the new nba
star because lebron is kind of
break down what you mean which is i'm a
little bit sensitive i need positive
reinforcement
i don't want you to yell at me i need to
be coddled a bit can we have our own
personal handshake
like a can't like cool handshake that's
just me and you and we'll do it between
you know every single period right maybe
at the beginning of every game too
that'd be really good
and as a guy who spent mad time in
therapy i get it
but i grew up in an indian household and
i also get the jimmy butler [ __ ] which
is like i don't got time for your
[ __ ] game it was like what jordan
used to be yeah
except jimmy will seems like co-sign you
more if you do well yeah
jordan wouldn't get pippin flowers like
jimmy's doing for tyler hero
yeah yeah yeah i mean tyler here was not
pimping but like horace grant or
whatever
fourth grand hated jordan yeah tyler
hero is like yo he's doing it this is a
guy who works his ass off he buys into
the culture
i'm gonna big up this [ __ ] every
time i get a chance so that point tyler
hero said he's like
i really want to get to the finals for
uh for jimmy it would be his first time
in the finals
now it's like you're a guy who's lived
and breathed basketball your whole life
yes you're only 20 but like
you've been dreaming about the finals
your whole life like yeah you want to
get there for you
but imagine like loving a teammate so
much that you want to see
them be there that's the first thing
that comes to your mind
that is dedication and you don't get
that unless you earn that respect
so one thing that i love about this
bubble is that like we
get to find out this really truly unique
character that is jimmy butler
when given the right situation can
really thrive and like make his
teammates better and it's really awesome
one thing that absolutely terrifies me
about it is that kyrie irving is
watching this going
see if i just have my right team yeah i
just have my right culture
this is what i could do yeah and that's
all that the only reason i've been
bouncing around is because i'm just like
jimmy i just don't have the right guys
around me but once i do i got this
that's fine let him keep thinking that
yeah i mean like but could could we also
make the argument
right that we said that about jimmy
before this
yeah i guess you could but i just think
also on top of everything kyrie's body
doesn't hold up
and everybody whenever i tweet the kai
reed stands are like
when kyrie is healthy when is kyrie
helping yeah
yeah yeah that's fine 40 games a year
jimmy butler is a [ __ ]
he is a healthy he's a man yeah you're
not taking him out of games that easily
i mean this guy built for it kyrie ain't
built for it he's three inches taller
than me
i mean get out of here buddy what do you
think happens what are your predictions
for the finals
i think i've people been telling me
miami this whole time my homie danish
picked miami in the first round he said
they're getting out of the east
i think i just hate them because they
beat the mavs and 06 but i haven't seen
it this whole time and i think
the last is going to overpower them but
they're clearly scrappy as [ __ ] i think
they take it to six
it's interesting isn't it yeah they're
gonna have to be lights out
because the only thing that i'm looking
at i'm looking at both squads and i'm
like
can la keep up with the fire power from
the three-point line
that miami has dude duncan robinson
tyler hero hero is
quick dog yeah he just shot up so fast
yeah yeah duncan robinson too
yeah and this is like so so what's gonna
happen there that's my curiosity
right is it i think the lakers got it
i don't think it should be difficult but
if
miami goes bananas from the three-point
line yeah
i don't know how la reacts to that
because who on la can really
knock down contavious caldwell pulp
on a good day danny green seems washed
maybe he can get it
i don't know so that's i think the other
i think that those guys got to come up
big and they got to really
they got to beat them from behind the
line i think this quarantine has
actually benefited lebron
the way it benefited chris paul and you
don't think about it because lebron
plays 45 minutes a game all the
time but he played less minutes this
year then got three months off then
hopped right into the playoffs
and if you've been watching lebron i
haven't watched every game but i see him
the games i see
he just [ __ ] takes over yeah because
i think he got the energy too
yeah he had a full off season and then
hop right into the playoffs and it's
just
when you watch i remember i saw lebron
live with the heat
playing the nets one playoff game and
they lost the game because lebron just
kind of let it come to him yeah
when lebron decides to take over there's
really nothing you can do even at 35
there's
nothing yeah he really closed out the
nuggets huh i mean yeah
yeah yeah you guys watch a little bit i
watched a little bit yeah yeah
i mean it was it was impressive it's
just different he's just locked in right
now in a way that i haven't seen before
and i think this is the the easiest by
far match of lebron has ever had in the
finals
this is the first time you're looking at
his team and you're like oh they're
heavy favorites
yeah maybe 2011 mavericks which he
wasn't ready for but then since then
when was the last time you saw
a lebron team overpower the other team
like this and think that's this heavy of
a favorite
yeah the spurs the first time he was
completely outclassed the warriors three
times in a row they always have more
talent
yeah and a better coach and better
system and all that it's funny i agree
with you
but for some reason i feel like that he
has a chance like the way they play
the team chemistry the trust that they
have in each other the fact that they
were even given
iguodala the ball when he was playing
like the
whole series and they just put that
trust in him and then he's [ __ ] lit
it up
like that's the team that hey they can
pull one out even from such a strong
team like the legacy yeah
i think they they're scrappy and i've
clearly slept on this whole time
i think they take it to six but i think
at the end the talent is just so
insurmountable does it show you like um
the importance of a of a culture yes
you know like yeah he'd have this
culture they talk about culture and then
they have players that are on the roster
not to play but simply to drive the
cultural value
yeah right like udonis haslam is not
there to play basketball nope
he is there to instill culture and make
sure the rooks
have someone they can go to but hold the
vets accountable because
you're not going to talk to udonis your
don is a dog too
yeah you know being like you're not
going to talk [ __ ] you might talk [ __ ]
to andrew wiggins sweet canadian kid
yeah you might talk uh [ __ ] to what is
it cat
whatever is [ __ ] skinny ankle ben
simmons and exactly you might talk [ __ ]
to me
but you're not going to talk [ __ ] like
that to you donnis right so
i wonder if you see other teams
go not only do we need to start building
a culture but we need to keep around the
players
that drive that culture yeah and even if
we're signing him to like veterans
minimums it doesn't matter it's worth
that
every player the heat has is a [ __ ]
workhorse bam out of bio by all accounts
that guy is nice nice and a [ __ ] like
he works
yes tyler hero this guy wasn't highly
regarded coming out of college how to
get so [ __ ] nice he clearly worked
duncan robinson undrafted you know
there's a great message there's a dm
duncan robinson is a senior at like
michigan
state or something like that i forget
which school he went to like some school
i think it's michigan
he dm's a writer for the ringer
and he goes hey man um uh you know i
listen to your podcast or i read your
stuff whatever it is and uh
i'm just really uh curious about you
know your line of work and i'm really
curious about like what you do and i'd
love to just you know pick your brain if
i could
he's literally in his senior year
preparing for not
playing basketball professionally that's
amazing and dm'ing for
job opportunities which is pretty cool
like taking the initiative right
and now he's in the nba finals amazing
and hooping his [ __ ] ass that's
amazing you know what theory i just had
about jimmy butler maybe the thing he
hates the most
is wasted talent is someone who doesn't
work to fulfill their potential
because i'm thinking about the players
he did not like andrew wiggins
talented [ __ ] kid number one pick
overall yeah didn't seem to want it you
didn't have the mentality to go get it
carl anthony town
anthony towns ben simmons we talk about
all the time how you not have a jumper i
think jimmy saw him said he don't
he don't want to fulfill his potential i
don't like that [ __ ] where did
he come
miami he loves tyler hero because tyler
hero is not a super talented guy
i think he sees a guy who works his ass
off because that's what jimmy was
jimmy was not highly regarded i remember
seeing him as a three and d
guy hey d up hit some threes you're good
worked his way into being an all-star
duncan robinson
undrafted worked his way into being the
best three-point shooter in the league
bam
mid-round pick mid first round pick
nothing special worked his way into
being a superstar potentially
i think jimmy loves that because he sees
himself in that interest and i think
superstars who don't fulfill their
potential
he sees what he wished he had and he
sees what he would have done with that
talent
and he [ __ ] hates that person that is
best case scenario for jimmy
yeah i wonder if worst case scenario is
he's threatened by superstars
interesting
and they make him act out
maybe i heard he loves joel embiid
though
and embiid is a guy who will take
attention away from everybody
he doesn't try at all joellenby gives
the least effort
that's true maybe not shape i mean like
maybe my whole theory is [ __ ]
yo i have a question yeah do you think
the passing of kobe bryant
or playing the last dance and like
watching the last dance has had an
impact on lebron psychologically and how
he approaches the finals
honestly i don't think so i i think that
lebron is
super like locked in and he understands
the goal and what he wants and like for
his legacy i don't
i think that like he's leaning into the
marketing of you know kobe's passing us
the torch and
we couldn't lose in the mamba jerseys
and like all those opportunities but i
think on like a personal level
no i think it i think kobe adds one or
two percent if he's 98
locked in this gets him at 99 99.5
because it's like
that was his friend who passed now i'm
wearing the [ __ ] jersey this guy like
i'm not um can't lose yeah it'd be
interesting to see what would have
happened
if the last dance came out
during the bubble oh
yeah because the last dance came out
right
and then while everything was shut down
so we were all super inspired by the
last dance
right like in the same way that like you
know izzy fights
last night right or izzy fights on
saturday right
and um i'm just so inspired inspired i
like go downstairs to my gym i started
hitting the [ __ ] punching bag and
[ __ ] like i'm kicking it
my hip is all [ __ ] up today because i
didn't old man problems but like
i think like immediately everybody's i'm
gonna be so locked in these playoffs
just like mj was
and because we live in the
you know in this content cycle where
everything is constantly being refreshed
and we
forget about it the last dance feels
like it was a year ago to me
like we reviewed it it feels like it was
365 days ago
yeah no that's fair i don't think that
they're holding on to it the same way
but imagine it came out
the same time oh it'd be nice as of the
finals nuts
imagine it came out in the week before
the finals so the downtime
people will be salivating nuts i mean
all these players would be going [ __ ]
berserk
let's go every game would have been a
[ __ ] war yeah
to that point though what did mj always
look for
when he was playing motivation extra
motivation even when you're that elite
and that locked in you need to find the
motivation
i think lebron's more than the last
answer would be kobe that was my
that was like my brother man he's gone
and i'm wearing his jersey it all feels
like he's supposed to be here now
this is the first time i'm not rooting
against the lakers i love hating the
lakers
i can't root against them this year if
they get it great man good for them i
think he feels that too of like yo
this is destiny this is i'm this is my
fourth ring let's go i'm locked in